foreign
[Music]
solitary confinement a punishment
inflicted on prisoners pet goldfish and
of course Lance Armstrong's remaining
testicle it's in there all by itself it
must be so lonely most of us have a
general idea of what solitary
confinement is well there was this
Tick-Tock man on the street interview
demonstrates others seem a little unsure
in solitary confinement how many
prisoners are in each cell
alone
yeah that's right
okay
I'm glad they got it right but it didn't
take them an alarming amount of time to
Triple team that answer although it did
also give me a chance to absorb every
weird fashion Choice there because you'd
think the boldest one would be this kid
wearing light blue Crocs with a
virginity rocks t-shirt but then you've
been knowing that this one is wearing
hashtag shoes this one's outfit is
somehow both too formal and too casual
and this one seemingly couldn't decide
if he was dressing for the pool or golf
so decided on both very basically every
one of these human red Solo cups is
dressed in wrong in their own unique way
I'm genuinely glad they all found each
other and I hope to never meet any of
them under any circumstances the point
is solitary confinement is a common
enough practice that even those Bros
basically know about it and the fact is
in this country facilities from jails
and prisons to immigration detention
centers isolate a massive number of
people a 2016 government report found
that on any given day an estimated 90
000 inmates in prison and jail are
housed in isolation and that is almost
certainly an undercount given how poor
data collection on this is yet for how
widespread our use of solitary is some
of those in charge of our prison systems
have been weirdly ignorant on the
practicalities of it take this amazing
exchange from 2014 where then Senator Al
Franken asked the then head of the
Federal Bureau of Prisons a pretty
simple question
how big is a cell
how big is the average cell in solitary
say that the average size sell yeah the
size of the cell how big is it
what is I'm trying to get this is the
human
thing we're talking about we've got a
lot of Statistics how big is the cell
the average size of a
cell is
I guess I'm trying to find you're
looking for the the space of what the
yes
the dimensions
in feet
in inches the size of the cell
that a person is kept in
I want to get some idea of I don't know
am I asking this wrong no
no you are absolutely not
and honestly I wish he kept going there
okay clearly you're confused by feet and
inches how about meters or steps you
know if you stood at one end of the cell
how many steps would it take to walk to
the other end no how many rabbits could
you fit on the floor and one of those
cells how many rabbits big is one cell
am I asking this wrong because there
were literally no other ways to ask this
question
for the record the average size of a
solitary cell is six feet by nine feet
which is way too small for a person to
be stuck in for days weeks months or
even years on end that level of
isolation is why in 2011 the United
Nations special rapporte on torture
declared that considering the severe
pain and suffering that solar energy
confinement can cause it can amount to
torture they then called on all
countries to prohibit indefinite and
prolonged solitary confinement in excess
of 15 days which really is not asking
that much but is also something that we
in the U.S have to put it mildly not
done which is just appalling a solitary
really takes a toll on people as someone
who's actually experienced it can tell
you ask yourself can you live in a
bathroom for 10 years
it's bad to lock an individual up and
just put them in a in a room a close you
know nothing to do it's it's
I guess you could say inhumane and I
know that we're inmates and all year and
but excuse my language it me up
yeah of course it you up human
beings are not meant to sit in a
bathroom for 10 years with nothing to do
you're thinking of retainers those are
the things that we place into a bathroom
and fully neglect for an entire decade
everybody knows that so given how
prevalent it is and how damaging it can
be tonight let's look at solitary
confinement so let's start with the fact
that it has its roots in a somewhat
unexpected place
it was actually introduced by the
Quakers as a noble experiment in
Rehabilitation there was a belief that
you could put a prisoner in his own
solitary cell freed from the evil
influences of modern society and if you
put them in that cell
they would become like a penitent Monk
free to come close to God and to their
own inner being and they would naturally
heal it's true the whole idea of
solitary came from Quakers and on one
hand it is not surprising that a form of
brutal torture and Punishment was
invented by a religious group but on the
other if you gave me 50 guesses for
which one invented locking people in a
small room alone to feel guilty 24 hours
a day I'd have guessed Catholics 50
times in a row
clankers
basically thought that prisoners
isolated themselves with a Bible could
use that time to reflect repent and
eventually reform that is even where the
term Penitentiary originated which is a
handy fun fact if you ever want to
quickly raise a few red flags on a first
date but by the mid-1800s the
psychological harms of isolation were
becoming clear and by 1890 the Supreme
Court declared that solitary confinement
made prisoners quote violently insane
after that the practice was largely
abandoned until the 1980s when mass
incarceration led to prison overcrowding
which in turn led to a rise in prison
violence and in an effort to preserve
order prison officials started ramping
up the use of solitary again and at this
point it is worth looking at what modern
solitary actually consists of generally
it involves isolating people for 22 to
24 hours per day in small cells with
minimal contact with others and with
little or no access to reading materials
or radio and TV and even that is pretty
much what you assumed
well elements to solitary that you might
not expect like the fact that some cells
are lit around the clock and that there
can be a near constant sound of banging
screaming and moaning Frontline spent
four months filming in a solitary
confinement unit and released a video
just of the noise and here is just 20
seconds of it
foreign
[Music]
holy how are you supposed to think
in there let alone sleep there is a
reason people fall asleep to sounds of
the rainforest and not sounds of one of
those haunted houses where you have to
sign a waiver to get in
so a person can be stuck alone in a Cell
for 23 hours a day or more with the
soundtrack to stomp playing in the
background and as this man will tell you
filling that time can take some real
effort one of the things I did in
solitary to pass the time was save my
bread put it on the floor and let the
mice come in and eat it and play it was
action it was something different is it
gross yeah disgusting a little bit sure
better than going insane
yeah right that makes sense doesn't it
because it is a little disgusting but it
is better than going insane also for
what it's worth I don't think I
understand what Tick Tock is I thought I
did but I clearly don't I thought
it was an app for teens to do the same
eight dance moves that all involve this
moved
so that the Chinese government can spy
on us I didn't know that Frank
discussions of the conditions of prisons
were part of it too but that guy wasn't
kidding there solitary can irreparably
damage people's minds studies show that
some lasting mental damage is caused
after just a few days of isolation and
the effects can be even more acute when
children experience it oh yeah in case I
forgot to mention we subject children to
solitary in this country too
Vicki Reed was shocked by what we found
at the Middle Tennessee Juvenile
Detention Facility in Murray County we
reveal juveniles often spend 23 to 24
hours a day locked inside their cells if
a parent locks their kid in a closet and
leaves them there and feeds them three
times a day and that's it we would call
that child abuse yeah she's not wrong if
I learned that someone was locking
children in a closet all day long I'd
immediately say two things all those the
children from the car for kids
commercial if so thank you for your
service but if not
then that is child abuse and you need to
stop doing it immediately
so if it is this torturous and this
permanently damaging why do we put
people in solitary well if you ask
prison or government officials the
response you'll often get is we actually
don't and that is because we have a lot
of euphemisms for solitary like
segregation or protective custody or
referring to themselves as restricted
housing units or security housing units
in Tennessee where that woman was
outraged that kids were being held in
isolation officials there simply called
it room restriction and here is New York
mayor Eric Adams trying to make a
similar type of semantic distinction I
am opposed to solitary confinement that
is a Draconian way to protect the city
but what I am saying you can't be a an
inmate sexually assault a correction
officer or another inmate and then state
in general population punitive
segregation is a humane way of removing
dangerous inmates to a location where
they can get the services they need so
they can stop praying in on other
inmates staff and praying on society you
just doesn't support solitary
confinement but he's all in for punitive
segregation an interesting distinction
considering that the New York Board of
Corrections own website says that
punitive segregation is also known as
solitary confinement so that's a pretty
weird stance to take although it
probably shouldn't be surprising that
Eric Adams did or said something weird
this is the same man who once told a
reporter that New York sits on a store
of rare gems and Stones which is why
there's a special energy that comes from
here insisted on taking his first
paycheck as mayor in crypto deliberately
posed for this photo and has repeatedly
held up a sponge on stage to encourage
people to ring out their internal
despair answering the question what if
Mr Clean was a motivational speaker
but the fact is whatever you call
solitary the experience for the person
going through it is the same and
Corrections Officers will often justify
the use of it by arguing as Adams just
did that is a necessary tool to isolate
wrongdoers and preserve order here is
the head of the New York City
Corrections Officers Union making that
exact point we have to be able to
segregate those people because you know
if we have a society without
consequences then we'll just have total
Anarchy isn't the problem that many of
those in solitary are not the really
dangerous criminals they're people
who've broken minor rules or are
suicidal
that's just not the case minor
infractions people do not end up in
solid in um funeral segregation
good catch you
you've almost called it as soon as you
can find my there I near Miss on par
with having a mustache that almost makes
you look like a John Waters impersonator
but
the second
the claim that people don't end up in
solitary for minor infractions is just
not true in general researchers have
found that violence is typically not the
most common reason that people are sent
to solitary in Oregon researchers once
found that Disobedience was the
infraction resulting in the most
solitary confinement sanctions and
Nationwide people who sent a solitary
for reasons including and these are all
real not making their bed using Facebook
and having too many envelopes and is
this formerly incarcerated man will tell
you the list does not stop there I've
seen people go to solitary for things as
little as handing other people's stuff
having too many cigarettes in their
pockets I've seen people go to solitary
for talking back I've seen people go to
solitary for not having their shirt
tucked in
I've seen people go to solitary for not
having the right shoes in the gym I've
seen people go to the box for a lot of
stuff bro that is ridiculous solitary
should not be where we send people who
are dressing incorrectly if it were I
can think of four people who've been
there right now yeah they said they're
walking around free struggling to answer
basic questions
so the truth is
Petty rule infractions are a very common
cause of Landing people in solitary and
that is not all people who are seen as
at risk in the general prison population
because they are young mentally ill
intellectually disabled gay or
transgender can wind up in there for
their own protection and think how
absurd that logic is the only way we can
keep you safe is to inflict enormous
harm on you it's like arguing the only
way to keep you hydrated is to
waterboard you one It Isn't So two find
another way and if you're
thinking well what if someone actually
is a Potential Threat to inmates or
guards shouldn't they then be getting
locked up in solitary well you should
know that a 2016 report found that there
is little evidence that administrative
segregation has had any effects on
overall levels of violence in
correctional facilities in fact some
researchers found subjecting people to
solitary can lead them to become more
not less violent and that can obviously
be a problem not just inside prisons but
also after people are released even
those who have worked within prisons
like this former Warden will tell you
just how counterproductive our current
system is if I have somebody that comes
in with a five-year commitment you can
have them do their whole time in
segregation but I don't want them living
next to me when you release it the
reality is that 80 of these inmates are
going to be hitting the street okay so
we can either make them worse okay and
create more victims when they go on the
street or we can rehabilitate right and
when you frame it as a choice like that
it is hard
solitary confinement
for dinner tonight we can either get
pizza or we could assassinate Paul
McCartney one of those choices makes
sense and the other is absolutely
horrible for everyone on Earth
and just to be clear
the people who've committed violent acts
in prison should just be left in the
general population to potentially harm
others they can be separated without
being completely isolated take North
Dakota they're State Prison officials
made the Bold decision to end the use of
solitary there but in doing so to also
create a less hostile atmosphere overall
so when prisoners got in trouble for
serious infractions like violence
instead of solitary they were sent to a
brand new unit where they'd get
significant out of cell time and access
to behavioral treatment and it has had
promising results
Jerry Holmes was just released from the
new Behavioral Health intervention unit
or biu in September mindset 100 better
coming out of the box Brandon Davis has
spent time in the old administrative
segregation unit or ASU and the new biu
he says the biggest difference is just
having someone to talk to now they have
interaction in counseling to work toward
a solution because if you bottle in your
issues it just it it overwhelms person
because I have my own problems
you're isolated and you have these
issues
and it's like you have nowhere to
release him or no one to talk to him
about of course you don't have to have
been in solitary to understand that
talking through your issues with other
people is probably better for you than
being locked up in a concrete toilet
cave and look I'm not saying that any of
this is easy because I know that the
solution should be simple here putting
people in solitary is torture so let's
stop doing it but exactly how we do that
is absolutely critical to any reform
actually working unfortunately in
multiple States when they've taken steps
to limit the use of solitary Corrections
officials have found ways around them by
doing things like keeping prisoners
isolated for just below the threshold
set by the state or creating even more
euphemisms to camouflage the practice
one key reason that North Dakota's
reforms worked is because they came
directly from people running the
correction system there they understood
that reducing the use of solitary
required a shift in the whole culture of
their prisons and they did have to get
rid of Staff who weren't on board with
the idea so that it could be executed
properly and while it was not easy there
was an initial rise in violence in the
prison's general population immediately
afterward they stuck with it and not
only has the overall trend in violence
been downward for both incarcerated
persons and staff members reported
improvements in their health and
well-being better interactions with one
another and less exposure to violence
following the reforms so it can be done
if we want to and I know that some
corrections officials will still insist
that they need solitary but I would
argue that if you find yourself making
the case that you need to torture people
to keep your facility safe that in
itself is an admission of catastrophic
failure and you may need to go because
it is important to remember just how
lasting the damage here can be the
voices in this debate are often
dominated by Corrections officials but
it is worth listening at length to the
people who've been harmed by this
Anthony Graves was kept in solitary for
18 years after being wrongly convicted
and just listen to him testify before
Congress about what it did to him
I have been free
for almost two years
and I still cry at night
because no one out here can relate to
what I've gone through
I battle with these feelings of
loneliness
I've tried therapy
but it didn't work
the therapist was crying more than me
she could not imagine
how inhumane our system would treat
people
I haven't had a good night's sleep since
I've been out I only sleep about two and
a half to three hours a night
and then I'm up
my body has not made the adjustment
I have mood swings that just causes
emotional breakdowns I don't know where
they come from they just come out of
nowhere
solitive confinement
makes our Criminal Justice System
Criminal
he's right solitary isn't something we
do to people behind bars it's something
we do to them forever and it needs to be
universally understood how utterly
indefensible it is so that maybe just
maybe one day in the future we can get
to a point where even if you approached
the worst dress Bros on the street of
any American city and ask them what is
the acceptable number of people to have
in solitary confinement the answer they
come up with with no hesitation is
zero